los sentidos
[Música]
o no
estos muros que se desmoronan están
hechos de un mineral llamado mica aunque
parece resistente se convierta en polvo
al cabo de algunos años miles de casas
en el condado de donegal en irlanda
fueron construidas con este material en
los últimos años los residentes han
visto como sus casas se derrumban ante
sus propios ojos y le piden al gobierno
que pague las reparaciones y también la
reconstrucción porque le preguntamos a
michael daugherty miembro del grupo de
acción contra la mitad de knight y hoy
irak and raq en el silencio de la noche
a veces se oye un crujido y este crujido
se hace tan fuerte que uno se despierta
inmediatamente uno espera que esta
grieta no sea adyacente a otra grieta
existente porque si se juntan puede
ocurrir un desastre y la pared y luego
el techo podrían derrumbarse
hola
tenemos niños que ya no pueden dormir en
sus habitaciones quieren dormir en la
habitación de sus padres
nos preocupa mucho mucho este invierno
que se aproxima
creemos que las casas se van a derrumbar
pronto estas grietas son lo
suficientemente grandes como para poder
meter la mano en algunas de ellas e
incluso se puede cavar en la pared
hubo un gran boom de la construcción en
irlanda las autoridades locales se
tomaron a la ligera la normativa que se
aplicaba entonces o que debería haberse
aplicado
corresponde a las empresas que extraen
las piedras y deberían auto regularse y
hacer cumplir las normas esto no se está
haciendo como debería
una cantera en concreto es responsable
de cerca del 80 por ciento de las 3.000
viviendas que creemos que están
afectando en donegal y el gobierno
permitió que esto ocurriera al no tener
una normativa debidamente aplicada en
ese momento
el gobierno irlandés ofrece actualmente
un programa a los propietarios de estas
viviendas para cubrir el costo de las
reparaciones sin embargo hay un límite
para las reparaciones lo que significa
que los afectados tienen que pagar
decenas de miles de euros de su propio
bolsillo los propietarios viajaron hasta
dublín la capital del país para
protestar y exigir una indemnización del
100 por ciento en todos los casos así
como una investigación pública sobre las
empresas responsables de este problema
y construir mi casa hace algo más de 20
años y durante los primeros 7 u 8 años
todo estuvo muy bien entonces empezamos
a notar algunas grietas me quedaban dos
años la hipoteca y la cantidad de dinero
que necesitaría hoy para completar el
programa de subvenciones que ofrece el
gobierno es en realidad más dinero del
que me costó construir mi casa hace 20
años tendría que pedir dos hipotecas
sobre la misma casa y no tengo los
medios para hacerlo
el grupo de acción contra la mica
calcula que al menos 6.000 viviendas del
condado de de nag han se han visto
afectadas por los derrumbes los
habitantes de los condados vecinos
también se han visto afectados por este
mismo problema lo que eleva el número
del total de los hogares afectados a
unos 10.000
y terminamos con la noticia falsa de la
semana que también pueden encontrar en
nuestras redes sociales
a continuación verán el más reciente
ejemplo de una noticia falsa contra los
musulmanes en la india
y ahora la gigante el arroz sur y en el
vídeo se ve que los musulmanes intentan
reducir la población hindú me está
poniendo productos químicos en el arroz
este vídeo es el más reciente ejemplo de
contenido de odio dirigido contra los
musulmanes en línea según la web ex en
boxes player este vídeo ha estado
circulando en twitter en facebook y
whatsapp con un texto que acusa a los
musulmanes de envenenar el arroz no
obstante en este vídeo hay pistas que
nos pueden guiar sobre el origen
escuchemos lo primero
la mezcla
[Música]
como lo pueden escuchar el vídeo está en
español y menciona palabras como arroz y
mezclar español en un vídeo grabado en
la india eso sería bastante extraño
también hay pistas visuales en estas
imágenes aquí y allá vemos una bolsa de
arroz y se lee catherine pero falta la
última letra así que al buscar arroz y
catherine en google el buscador nos
sugiere arroz caserita en efecto se
trata de la misma bolsa de arroz y se
puede ver incluso que se vende
principalmente en los mercados de perú
basándonos en estas pistas e
investigando las noticias de perú de los
últimos años encontramos el vídeo en
artículos y noticias del año 2018 según
una televisión local las personas que
aparecen en el vídeo habían vertido en
el arroz un líquido a base de achiote un
pigmento rojo para colorear el arroz y
también habían añadido aceite para que
el arroz pareciera de mejor calidad en
las redes sociales algunos habían
llegado a afirmar que este arroz había
llegado al mercado de santa anita en
lima la capital de perú los vendedores
negar haber recibido este tipo de arroz
acá nos está adulterando nada lo que
pasa que nos están haciendo una
difamación
de vido no sé a qué se debe esto pero
nosotros acá el arroz del mercado
productores de santa anita vendemos así
como llega de chiclayo en cualquier caso
este vídeo no muestra a algunos
musulmanes supuestamente envenenando
arroz en india ya que el vídeo fue
grabado en 2018 en perú cabe destacar
que la policía peruana no anunció en
ningún momento alguna información sobre
las modificaciones al arroz y tampoco
alguna detención
es todo por esta semana en los
observadores si tiene alguna historia
que podría interesar nos pueden escribir
a nuestra redacción todos los puntos de
contacto aparecen en sus pantallas
esperamos sus fotos y sus vídeos tal vez
usted puede hacer nuestro próximo
observador hasta entonces